- What up guys?
Finally caught up on DailyVee,
we had a ton in the can,
I'm sure you noticed,
but now we're finally back
on track with DailyVee,
caught up to date, this
is from two days ago,
we're back in our cadence.
2019 swags, I hope you enjoy it.
I want to give away all of
my marketing advice for free,
and don't care if I get a penny for it,
which then leads me to get pennies for it.
(loud music)
Yo.
How are you?
I can, let's rock and roll.
Everybody's in a short-term bro.
Everybody wants a, like,
do you know that ninety-five
percent of the people
listening here tried to do social media
but after one to four months,
they gave up because they
didn't see a sale from it,
because ninety-nine percent of people
when they do social media
are trying to take steroids.
People don't get it man.
People are just so hungry
for short-term affirmation
that they're willing to undermine
their long-term success.
(music)
And ninety-nine percent of
people's social media behavior
is selfish.
Ninety-nine percent of the people
listening to this right now
only care about selling a home,
not actually educating somebody
how to get a better home.
Do you know why I'm one of
the most followed people?
Because I want to give away
all of my marketing advice for free,
and don't care if I get a penny for it
which then leads me to get pennies for it.
(music)
You just have to document.
Documenting doesn't come
natural to everybody,
'cause everyone thinks
what they do is boring,
they don't realize it's
unique, that's what works.
Reality TV works,
like people want to see what's
happening in people's lives,
if, you know, if you have nothing to say,
you have the documentation of your day.
I mean the themes are just
reverse engineering the audience,
right, like how do we bring
more value tactically,
um, is really what I'm focused on, right,
like if you're not going to Agent2021
and not realizing modern digital execution
is what you're there for,
now it's about the details.
You know, more Q and A, more
deeper expertise of tactitions,
who've executed in mortgage or real estate
or things of that nature, so
just more depth of detail.
Linkedin long-form
creative to build expertise
or podcast to be the
commercial real estate expert
of a region,
I couldn't get people more to understand
that they have to become media
personalities or entities.
Spit out all their expertise,
and then use that leverage
to garnish business.
You know, an article on Linkedin is
five seconds away from
going viral that's called,
"What Seven Things You
Need To Look Out For
When You Open Your Second Location."
And if you're the one who wrote it,
and I read it 'cause I'm
opening my second wine library,
because I live on Linkedin and Facebook
like everybody else does,
whether you're eight or eighty-eight,
and then I see that you're actually
a commercial real estate person,
I might just message you from Linkedin
and now that article led to me using you.
This is happening every day, brother.
This is happening in
B-to-B software sales,
this is happening in real estate,
this is happening in politics,
like, I just, I'm fascinated by people
not willing to put in the work
out of laziness or success.
The people that are winning
right now are in the middle,
are in the middle, ironically,
you got the people to the
left that are just lazy
and they don't want to put in the work,
they hear me but they don't
want to put in the work,
and then you have a group of people
who are so successful right now,
they don't think they're in trouble.
The veterans that I know,
you know, and I know a lot of them,
are more interested in just
selling off their reputation,
and when they hear me talk,
they're like, 'yeah that's cool but like
I'm the queen bee in Malibu.
Everybody knows who I am,
I don't need Gary's bull crap of like,
putting in Instagram.
It doesn't matter, it's going to,
like I don't want to put
out social because I'm,
I'm like high end.'
or they just come up with excuses
because they can still get away with it,
but here's what they don't realize.
On the next downturn
on the economic crisis,
which is inevitable,
when the Phoenix rises,
it's going to be all
the twenty-six-year-olds
that build a brand during this era,
and then they won't be
the queen bee anymore,
they're gonna be the has been.
But the problem is, they're
not ready to retire.
(music)
Ah, dude, I love you for
like setting that up.
Like everybody's faking.
Like I'd much rather
see you do your listings
in a Toyota that has like a bum tire
'cause it's your truth.
Like if you're faking the Maserati
and the five thousand dollar suit,
what are you going to do when
I run into you at the restaurant?
You don't have to fake it til you make it,
and everybody in real estate and sales,
everyone's trying to posture,
wearing a suit, this and that.
Like literally renting a limousine,
or a Lamborghini,
I mean everybody's faking bro,
I was like, go tell the truth.
Like tell the truth of your journey.
Document, don't, you have nothing to say.
All you have to say is the
documentation of the journey,
of becoming a real estate agent.
Then, people start getting into you
out of your authenticity and truth,
and then in three years,
you might be able to start actually
getting the results of that.
Now if somebody listening here
is seventeen years in the business,
what she or he can do is tell,
put out content about
things that they know
are tried and true.
Mistake, nobody's bringing,
the reason I would dominate real estate is
I would just give away the secrets.
I'd be like, yo,
here's the things that
you need to look out for.
Here's where people get caught on taxes.
Here's what people get
caught on, on inspections.
Here's what you need to think about
when you're merchandising.
Cinnamon cookies do this, candles do that.
I would literally do what
I'm doing with marketing,
and what I did with wine.
Why have I been able to over-index
in both things that I've done.
I gave away all the truths,
all the industry secrets,
I opened up the kimono in the wine world.
This isn't worth it, this is worth it,
this is what you should pay for it.
Want to get better wine,
try different things.
Why am I dominating in marketing?
I put out eighty-six page slides
that people charge five thousand
dollars for as an ebook,
and I put it away for free, and daily,
I put away content for free,
and then I tell people,
don't listen to me, watch me,
so if I'm doing this, you do that,
and that's why there's
tens of thousands of people
who've made a lot of money,
or found a lot of happiness
on the back of my content.
Yep, yep,
there's a wide-open space
in the real estate industry,
because everybody's short-term selfish.
Figure out how to be long-term giving
and watch your business grow in 2022.
Thank you brother.
Talk to you.